En échange, le gouvernement a accepté de protéger 30% de ses zones maritimes.
Les Seychelles sont sur la bonne voie pour protéger
400 000 kilomètres carrés d'océan.
C'est une zone d'environ la taille de l'Allemagne.
Les Seychelles protègent leurs récifs coralliens,
régénèrent leurs zones de pêche,
améliorent leur résistance au changement climatique.
En même temps, elles renforcent leur économie.
D'autres gouvernements prennent note de cette réussite.
Beaucoup veulent y participer.
Il y a une opportunité d'amplifier considérablement cette idée.
Et rapidement.
TNC a identifié 20 autres nations où un tel projet devrait être possible.
Mais il lui faut un capital de démarrage.
Et créer des équipes locales développant des projets de conservation,
travaillant avec les acteurs, structurant les accords.
Avec le soutien nécessaire durant les cinq prochaines années,
ils protègeraient quatre millions de kilomètres carrés d'océan.
C'est 10 fois l'Allemagne.
Cela augmenterait la surface des zones protégées
dans les océans du monde
de 15%, c'est incroyable.
Cela permettrait la régénération de vastes étendues de récifs coralliens
et offrirait un refuge sûr à d'innombrables espèces.
Cela serait incroyable.
Et ce n'est que le début.
Car il n'y a pas que 20 pays dans le monde
où une telle conversion de la dette marcherait.
Il y en a près de 100.
Avec cette approche, tout le monde y gagne.
Les gouvernements, les citoyens locaux, les donateurs
et surtout, nos océans.
En fait, nous y gagnons tous.
Ah, les océans terrestres...
[The Audacious Project]